I looked after Kate Moss briefly I
looked after
um Russell Crowe quite a bit actually
Russell's awesome
um Tom Cruise a Brad and Angie he
couldn't trust the drivers and I used to
catch him out all the time you know a
lot of the drivers would say okay
tomorrow morning
we're gonna go down to Smith's make sure
you're there on time do a wreck he did
it yeah no problem nothing for well I
ain't going there jump in the car got to
turn right at the gate that morning and
I've got no turn left but you sure we're
going to Smith's no we're not we're
going to Dailies
I'll go send the next drive go down to
Smith's tell me what you see drive down
to Smith's oh all the paparazzi are
there oh really really you just you
couldn't trust anybody mate so you had
to constantly having to be one step
ahead of the curve to just to get the
day's job done you know